allez vous amuser bas on commence avec
macron avec cette parodie qui a été fait
sur les réseaux il ya eu ce discours
très attendu du président et ça a été
détourné et regardez bien ce qui va se
passer maintenant j'ai pleuré ce matin
en réunion de rire regardez françaises
français
mes chers compatriotes de l'hexagone et
d'outre-mer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais moi je suis trop bekale des
pressions françaises français mes chers
compatriotes de l'hexagone et
d'outre-mer
on va courir et il y en a tous
évidemment une part de responsabilité
voilà selon prudente des ders là pour
nous les mains frater naira etc
je crois d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
vous a demandé magali bertin alors je
vais déjà eu deux minutes de faire
passer des messages via les influenceurs
pour passer des messages pour la
prévention de soins virus
alors oui on vous a effectivement
demandé vous qui est en excellente
influenceurs de faire des plongeurs pas
non plus très bien parce que le
gouvernement justement passe par les
réseaux sociaux pour diffuser bas les
gestes barrières et pour demander aux
influenceurs de faire bien sûr
gracieusement et à titre gratuit puisque
c'est d'intérêt public logement détruit
pas encore postés premier toujours être
là mais c'est intérêt public et aussi de
mettre le lien du
beaucoup de panique beaucoup de choses
qui se disent qu'ils sont pas vraies
donc si vous avez des questions si vous
vous posez des questions
le mieux c'est de cliquer sur ce lien
pour avoir vos réponses et ce sera les
meilleurs et je voudrais d'ailleurs
juste après l'émission match à mayol
alors justement aller à des
répercussions partout dans la vie de
tous les jours évidemment aussi dans le
football et vous allez voir les matchs
de ronaldo qui avec beaucoup d'humour
descend de son cas où d'habitude il ya
beaucoup de supporters et la phase aller
ils jouent le jeu regardez
byers et mis en quarantaine parce
qu'arrêter la ligue 2 est arrêté et
imaginer le psg se qualifie en finale et
là on annule la sapso de l'x ça serait
quand même pas de bol il ya une personne
qui présente m6 boutique une jeune femme
et je ne sais pas à quoi elle marche
elle un signal mais laurent parra -
florence web mail avec nous demain alors
lot lance laurence peraud elle est avec
nous alors allait à la pêche une énergie
c'est à lui elle est géniale cessé
d'être en un homme qu'elle a merkel
c'est le contraire vous matinaux regard
des rochers peur choisissez le de luxe
comme moi 232% youth et l'innovation
c'est le de luxe ouais je parle de moi
je suis de luxe
en plus de sa beauté c'est le first time
was the proposition
c'est la première fois qu'on vous le
propose james ouailles
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi wen wei
pourquoi 10 des durs comme ça à boire et
aujourd'hui tout tout tout tout c'est
l'anniversaire ça va être une offre de
ouf une offre de godard une offre méga
d'arca nous fêtons les 32 ans lieu où il
contrôle également que chacun coûtant
[Applaudissements]
radeema jeu serré les rangs derrière
vous avez d'ailleurs mon cher bernard
saïda thoiry et thierry beccaro nourrir
belle émission et ben justement pas être
le tchèque beccaro oui il ya une
carrosserie modus mais regardez embrassé
sur la bouche en apporter plus original
en régie ou en boîte ce qu'ils voulaient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire que l'émission allait
délirante de mais toujours dérangé mais
les graves plus ma demi-finale et 58 et
1 courir c'est quand ma fille était l
oreillette de na li té et ben beccaro
pas forcément il y des choses qui ne lui
ressemble pas regardé josy série de
questions je branche mon oreillette sûrs
et marqué de relief à une série de
questions allez vas-y doit de répondre
en respectant évidemment les réponses de
ton meilleur pote de baffie ok bah oui
très bien pourquoi la boule noire fils
de [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le nombre de masures si vite alors je
l'aï promis je le réclame depuis des
semaines on se moque souvent des génies
du paf qui sont hantées lhérété soit
autres chaînes et on a fait nos génies à
nous sont toutes vos pères vos pairs il
ya même les miennes ayons aussi avec
d'ailleurs je fais de ton regard des cc
cadeau c'est très drôle à regarder
on va passer maintenant donc je démenti
et je vous le dis je vais voter je vais
manger des montréalais pierre jean
pierre changeux chalossais moi je vous
le dit c'est faux j'ai accouché
j'assiste regarder ça que miss france de
france vas-y interview à titre posthume
je vais pas dire que parmi les premières
interviews dur à frédéric mitterrand et
les dix 10 mois d'été ont pas mort
millions d'utilisateurs bien une fois le
coup france par an une fois en france
par an merci merci il avait accusé un
poison il fallait le qg de la tête aux
pieds et je ne savais même pas
j'en ai commandé d'autres vont très
prochainement mais c'est vrai qu'on fait
on fait des efforts démesurés
on est à hollywood un haut niveau je
suis fier les écoles sont fermées c'est
embêtant
allez on a également les génies du paf
les vrais ceux de la télé a été regardée
depuis je vous l'apprenions par contre
aurait aidé brassier il est grave on le
sait mais on fait un nul ton prénom et
vidal n est un x2 mon prénom celui de
copies alias hot lixx maille fine
gravure maeva que vous voyez là c'est de
ce tout petit non il n'est pas stupide
non non non et non pas dans ce sens je
vous jure j'ai déjeuné avec elle et mes
deux fois d'ailleurs à la fille
situation en fait mais moi j'avais pas
ce quart est pas des auteurs derrière
tout ça comme n'ont absolument pas des
mauvaises auteurs n'ont pas besoin
d'auteurs scénarisé vis à vis sur
snapfish à toute la journée si tu veux
tu peux la suite tu verras les pareil
c'est leur métier la télé-réalité c'est
qu'un blizzard est donc fort à maintenir
le buzz
mais en même temps vous insultez les
jeunes qui regardent ces émissions et en
ce moment ça leur fait du bien laisser
les regarder se dit comment avec tout ce
qui se passe laisser leur sang
lors du rythme réseau les bons laissez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous fait penser à brigitte m'a croisé à
cause de ce petit tailleur lâchement on
veut jouer madame c'est la coupe de la
coupe de jeu chamaillard son mari à mes
côtés monge et kevin ça va très ça va ça
on va on va avancer avec ce que j'adore
4 maillage de bienne alors c'est vrai
que le principe de l'émission c'est en
gros d'assister à un mariage mais faut
pas se mentir le jeu favori de tout le
monde c'est moi ces deux crises
tellement déçue par son mariage que je
ne suis absolument pas inquiète pour le
mien mais derrière
la faim quant à ce retour en ligne comme
ça qu elle se balance
oui toi tu as dis ça tu m'as déçue je ne
suis pas mais là par le plus aux prises
le tournage était coupé parce qu'ils
sont bagarrés 2,3 et coupé on arrête et
on recommence dévoreur c'est le jeu
l'émission existe depuis dix ans donc je
mens c'est un truc ça va faire 4 fois
l'émission mon âme ouais ouais ouais
d'abord gagner un petit voyage et est ce
que ça fonctionne toujours oui oui ça
fonctionne toujours
[Rires]
moi ça me rattraper il arrive chez vous
pour vous quand je me suis marié donc la
deuxième fois on est on est mi liste de
mariage dans une agence de voyage et
enfin je vois les gens qui vont faire un
don à 10 ans voit très bien et je vois
prisma presse et à l'époque avec flavie
on était harcelée par les paparazzis et
c'est vous et des procès en permanence à
voici et figurez-vous que voici avait
fait cadeau sur ma liste de mariage pour
m'envoyer en voyage pour me après me
paparazzé oui bien sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après on m'a raté et j'ai réattaqué
[Rires]
c'est un business 1
alors après marjah après les matches
aller avant les divorces et les enfants
allez donc il ya les bébés sont blancs
baby boom bon bah ouais bah vous allez
me faire ça c'est typiquement a
franchement c'est un problème pour les
femmes parce que moi les gens en vrai
quand je vois un accouchement je suis
trop vieille man
oui oui maintenant 15 ans qui n'a pas
son bien censée mater brigitte alors à
quoi bon voilà je sais pas où on dit pas
ça fait n 62 que normalement je déconne
ah bon je veux aller baby-boom baby baby
boom mais sans le bébé dont baby boom
vous allez découvrir un futur papa qui a
l'air plus fatigué que la maman et c'est
bien normal moi je compatis vraiment de
tout coeur les yeux qui piquent de
soleil et remplit un vide avant les
arroseurs arrosés mythique homme une
femme enceinte
moi je serais tu rêvais quand les points
de la tête
c'était très calme
le groupe dodo
cette acquisition
vous donnez tous les nuages ou moi j'ai
compati c'est comme ça bah moi moi
j'étais pire parce que quand tu es zoé
est né laissant que ce qu'elle avait
c'est l'anniversaire de ma soeur donc
j'étais parti faire la fête et je suis
arrivé comme dans le livre est jeanne au
furet mais la clinique est composé de
travail et on m'a dit de me calmer bien
sûr parce que je fais beaucoup de bruit
dans la clinique est très content d'être
père mais voilà à consommer avec
modération bien évidemment comme va sans
dire voilà on va avancer cette émission
sur m6 sur les courses de chevaux
whitmire été déprogrammé marché
apparemment donc alors et maxime vous
l'avez fait je les fait il ya où il ya
trop de trop d'état imposé les bonnes
questions et fait progresser l'audience
et donc en gros c'est un joli un sérieux
problème de payer par le pmu voilà c'est
une affaire de jeunes à faire doser les
pas du tout mais on sera triste voilà et
visiblement il va inviter à leucate
balzac de souvigné
l'espoir finir c'est topless 6e 11e
c'est le n9 déroutés par le magic est
11e nokia petit j'aime cette qualité lui
a caché donnez lui un cas chez moi
mais ces deux points sur programmée le
matin le samedi matin dans 11 heures et
ça vous avait 80 mille téléspectateurs
1000 milles moyenne
c'est quasiment la mare d'audience la
marge d'erreur d'erreur de bêtise ça ne
vous regarde lui il a dormi toutes les
nations
là bas ils s'étaient tous les sujets ont
sauté c'est vrai mais ça l'est pourquoi
parce que magali n'est pas en phase donc
il n'a pas le bonheur
je n'ai pas on va poursuivre zapping si
vous le permettez
avec ces images étonnantes comme j'ai
oublié ce que c'était
regardez les pisteurs eux craignent pour
sa vie
en effet si l'os a sectionné l'artère
fémorale
l'homme est en danger de mort c'est une
immersion à mille à l'heure signé
christophe aubry nous est arrivé
[Applaudissements]
votre maman alors j'adore j'adore jean
marc hé oui la nouvelle idole de 2,20
lui sonar est douce et comme anodin sur
ces villes il n'y a pas d'autres
éditeurs de 7,6 par d'nrj12 ils peuvent
faire et la bêtise bah oui c'est la
merde mais là il parlait un peu comme un
gps
nous allons voir un nouveau sujet qui
apparemment est un peu fatigués ils
venaient jean marin très bien l apal
coronavirus merci beaucoup et on en
remarque aller toutes les émissions qui
marche très très bien dans la dernière
urgence qui a fait 400 grammes il
exactement
vous êtes incroyables allez on va
enchaîner que ces images dont m la vie
oui ça me revient ce sont les huiles des
enfants la télévision qui était en
direct ça marchait au bord oui oui c'est
pas mal il y avait bien que profiter
mais chantal ladesou et qui devait qui
devait en fait d'écrire tous les invités
et elle a confondu une chanteuse avec
une autre à regarder ces deux là dessous
c'est formidable c'est maintenant
florent peyre mais à côté il l'a raconté
jennifer
[Musique]
[Rires]
bah oui ça peut arriver
pour jennifer